Narrator: Disney released
the second trailer
for its remake of the
classic film "The Lion King."
In it we get a glimpse
of the main characters,
and we finally get to
hear some of them speak
for the very first time.
Though the film is still
technically animated,
this version is a more
photo-realistic take on the story.
There are also lots of shots that mirror
the original animated film.
Here is everything you might have missed.
The trailer opens with
young Simba and Nala
walking through the Elephant Graveyard.
This is the wasteland beyond the borders
of the Pride Land where
Simba is told not to go.
Mufasa: You must never go there, Simba.
Narrator: It's also the home
of the three hyena villains,
Shenzi, Banzai, and Ed.
We hear Scar, voiced by
Chiwetel Ejiofor, say...
Scar: Life's not fair.
Narrator: A classic line from the film
in which he's talking to a
mouse that he's about to eat.
Scar: Life's not fair, is it?
Narrator: While the Scar in the new film
seems to have the same
scar over his left eye,
he has a piece of flesh
missing from his right ear.
He also doesn't have the
green eyes from the cartoon,
which makes sense since
the movie is going for
a more realistic look.
Next, we see a shot straight
out of the original film
with the birds flying over
the water of the Pride Lands
and Simba on top of the cliff
with his father, Mufasa.
James Earl Jones reprises his role
as the voice in the remake.
Mufasa: A true king searches
for what he can give.
Narrator: The trailer also
gives us our first look
at Zazu, the red-billed hornbill,
voiced by comedian John Oliver.
He's the majordomo or chief
steward to King Mufasa.
Mufasa: What am I going to do with him?
Zazu: He'd make a very handsome throw rug.
Narrator: We also see a
pretty close shot-for-shot
version of the scene just
after the Elephant Graveyard
in which Mufasa and Zazu are leading Simba
and Nala back home in shame.
There's even a recreation
of the iconic moment
when young Simba puts his
paw in his father's print.
We also see the wildebeest
stampede orchestrated by Scar,
which results in the death of Mufasa,
and Scar telling Simba...
Scar: Run away, Simba, and never return.
Scar: Run away and never return.
Narrator: Two more memorable characters
we get a first look at in the new trailer
are the meerkat, Timon,
and warthog, Pumbaa,
voiced by Billy Eichner and Seth Rogen.
We see them walking with Simba
in an almost exact recreation
of the original scene,
a time-lapse of Simba
growing older during "Hakuna Matata."
Timon: Hakuna Matata!
Narrator: While the trailer
shows Simba eyeing a beetle,
in the original, Pumbaa is
the one chasing the bug.
After Simba and Nala finally reunite,
they are seen drinking water together,
which you might remember during the song,
"Can You Feel the Love Tonight."
We see almost the exact same
scene in the new trailer.
The adult versions of these characters
will be voiced by Donald Glover
and Beyoncé Knowles-Carter.
Meanwhile, Rafiki is painting
a red mane around Simba's image.
In the original film, he does this
when he realizes Simba is
still alive and is now matured.
After Scar dies and Simba reclaims
his rightful spot on the throne,
we see him walk up the cliff
and roar in the pouring rain,
another scene nearly
identical to the original.
The trailer basically gives us
a taste of what we can expect
from start to finish.
While we don't hear any of
the famous musical numbers,
there's a slight tease at the end.
We hear a snippet of Timon and Pumbaa
singing "In the Jungle"
just as they did in the original.
♪ In the jungle ♪
♪ A-weema-weh, a-weema-weh ♪
♪ The mighty jungle ♪
♪ A-weema-weh, a-weema-weh,
a-weema-weh, a-weema-weh ♪
Narrator: We can likely expect to see more
and hear more of the music from
the film in the days to come
ahead of the movie's release in July 2019.